as the journey of the ancient one
continued leading him ever closer to his
encounter with dr. Stephen strange one
of the world's most dangerous villains
was emerging while almost nothing is
known about his parents or birthplace
what is known is that as a child
Nathaniel Essex was gifted with an
aptitude for intelligence which largely
went unexplored until his adolescence
journeying to Greenwich Park in London
Essex did not view the world like
everyone else were the citizens of
London looked to religion as an answer
to their purpose in life Essex believed
that the gods were but one facet of the
universe with humanity moving forward
toward his guaranteed future applying
his intelligence as a means to
understand the place of humanity within
the cosmos Essex received a full
scholarship to Oxford University where
he pursued a career in biology becoming
obsessed with evolution Essex came to
believe that humanity stood upon the
precipice of change and that if it had
not begun already
a time would come when human beings
would begin to evolve creating a crude
representation of what these future
humans may look like Nathaniel Essex was
denounced and exiled from the royal
academy of sciences
all the while remaining completely
unaware that he was being watched by
curious eyes despite having lived for
thousands of years in travelling to
virtually every corner of the world
apocalypse had remained woefully
oblivious to his true heritage
disguising himself as a benefactor and
travelling to London through their
conversations and investigations
apocalypse came to realize that his
powers did not hail from divine
intervention but through a mutation in
his genes offering Nathaniel the
opportunity to continue his
experimentation without the restriction
of age
apocalypse use his celestial technology
to modify the genes of Essex allowing
him to go forward as mr. sinister
well the journeys of Essex would see him
continuing his experiments on the other
side of the Atlantic Ocean another
mutant was emerging nestled within
Alberta Canada's Lakeland District in
1885 James Howlett was born to Elizabeth
Hallett and the family's ground keeper
Thomas Logan ignored by his mother and
shunned by his father James spent the
early days of his youth under the abuse
of control of his grandfather who
routinely beat his grandson believing
that a firm and harsh brain was
necessary it's spending his time with
two other children named rose and dog
the biological son of Thomas Logan and
half-brother to James as the three grew
into adulthood their attention began to
shift to romance finding himself
attracted to Rose because dog had
experienced such brutal punishment at
the hands of his father like a feral
animal Dodd forced himself on DeRose
leading to the expulsion of both dog and
his father from the hallowed estate
flying into a drunken rage Thomas
returned to the estate murdering James
father in front of him overtaken by
grief and rage the powers of James
manifested resulting in the protrusion
of bone claws and a healing factor after
which James killed Thomas and left his
home alongside rose
moving away from Earth and transitioning
to a frontier world in the Crab Nebula
Thanos continued his journey living an
empty and unfulfilled life
Thanos produced children looted the
worlds of Fringe galaxies and murdered
failing to fill the void of his life the
more children he produced the more
people he killed and the more worlds he
pillaged the less he felt instead and
despite his best efforts his thoughts
wandered across the vastness of space to
the young girl on Titan who guided him
towards his first steps in killing
curious as to her whereabouts
Thanos his attempt to drive her from his
mind saw him taking up work on the
coast a pirate vessel led by a demented
captain challenging the captain for
leadership of the Pirates Thanos his
victory saw him giving in to his
bloodlust going forward as the mad Titan
however with the mysterious young girl
tormenting his every waking thought and
every sleeping dream
Thanos took his pirates and returned
home in an effort to find her
back on earth the 1793 advent of the
cotton gin had marked the midway point
of the Industrial Revolution and where
technology was advancing to allow for a
better understanding of the world
unbeknownst to all the entity sublime
watched closely evolving with the first
forms of life on Earth
sublime had spent countless eons jumping
from one house to the next using each
human to carry out its schemes and
sowing chaos and reaping Wars however
with the emergence of mutants the
alteration to their genetic code made
them immune to the influence of sublime
as such the entity began laying plans
for weapons plus a program rooted in the
idea of creating super soldiers during
this time the kingdom of austria-hungary
remained the weakest of the first world
nations a situation exacerbated by the
desire of the South Slavic people to
break away and form their own nation of
Yugoslavia where most look to diplomacy
as a means to achieve their goal a group
of Serbian nationalists calling
themselves a black hand chose another
path intending to eliminate Franz
Ferdinand the nephew of austria-hungary
Emperor Franz Josef the black hands
belief was that in doing so friends
Joseph would acquiesce and allow this
house Slavs to break away carrying their
mission to its completion instead of
allowing the South Slavs to form their
own nation and for Franz Josef waged war
international alliances were invoked and
World War one began as the powers of the
world squabbled over land and glory
sublime continued to operate in the
shadows using the post-world War One
chaos of Central Europe to his advantage
sublime took over the body of a human
host dubbing himself John and began to
manipulate various intelligence agencies
around the United States
arguing that the threat of world war one
proposed a legitimate need for
super-powered beings who would fight on
behalf of the United States sublime was
given a blank cheque by the US
government using those funds to bring
his vision into reality
coinciding with Hitler's invasion of
Poland and the start of World War two
word had reached the ears of sublime
regarding a German scientist who had
successfully developed a serum that
augmented the abilities of normal men
working alongside the United States
military
John sublime orchestrated the kidnapping
of dr. Abraham Erskine by Nick Fury and
his Howling Commandos after which
Erskine was sent a task and locating the
best suitable candidate for the use of
his formula spending several years
sorting through various soldiers Abraham
Erskine finally settled on a young
emaciated man whose lack of size
hindered his attempts to enter the US
Army electing to meet the boy in person
dr. Erskine was impressed by the man's
courage and bravery leading to the
development of the web and projects for
a successful test subject in the form of
Captain America origins of superpowers
are always very interesting if you get
the right origin like for example
spider-man being bitten by a radioactive
spider at least then the viewer has
something to hold on to and to say well
it might have happened
now I'll enjoy it
I can tell you exactly when timely
comics became Marvel the last name they
had before they became Marvel was Atlas
comics and after we did the Fantastic
Four we did the Hulk spider-man the
x-men so forth we suddenly began to
realize hey we've got fans so I decided
we ought to change the name of the
company get something better than Atlas
and the very first book that martin
goodman had ever published was called
marvel comics